so this is going to be a little bit in
ways philosophical and what I'm going to
look at is I'm going to look at how to
take assumptions that we see being made
in various models in biology and how to
reconcile them and in sort of ways how
do you CSD reject check do these
assumptions actually correspond to each
other or do they clash is there some
contradictions and that's kind of the
broad goal and I'll concentrate on sort
of a some storm able reason about static
fitness landscapes right and in
particular we'll look at this issue that
we've seen come up over and over again
which our originals were right and this
is the idea that in a rugged fitness
landscape we have local Fitness Peaks
somehow magically we get to them quickly
and then our questions are implicitly in
the language that we use how do we go
from one local Fitness speak to a higher
local Fitness peak right and the
question is is this at all a reasonable
statement and you can say for instance
talk part 1 in a lot of case we rested
the hypotheses on the fact that you can
get to a local Fitness peak right is
this always the case can you always get
to local local Fitness speak quickly in
a static fitness landscape and again as
was pointed out to talks ago you know
all of these things are more interesting
if you look at dynamic fitness landscape
etc etc for looking at the base case of
the simplest thing that can do if you
have a more complicated model you can
probably embed these smaller models
inside of it and get the hardest results
anyways and that's we're going to contra
as well as sort of showing that things
are hard as opposed to showing that
things are easier doable and so what are
these sort of empirical fitness
landscapes look like well the first
thing that a lot of biologists care
about is this idea of epistasis right so
you'll have some too low side and
they'll have let's say alleles a and B
right you'll have some federal eels a
beam and we'll say there's no epistasis
oh there's only magnitude of the stasis
if either way of getting there for swim
swapping an a or first swapping and B
our adaptive paths right so going from
here to here Houston fitness whomp you
increase the fitness same here right and
it's sort of your standard case of no of
the spaces between these two low site
and or or magnitude stasis which we
won't it won't really matter for the
sort of the 10 mile cs3 perspective but
it does matter in practice obviously on
the other hand it might be the case that
sometimes one of the paths is blocked
all right we can't swamp in be before we
swap in a all right so if we were to
swap in a it's it's adaptive but if
you'll just trust let's try to slop it
swamp in the uppercase B first we can't
there's a there's a fitness value that
we have to walk into right and this is
called sign up of stasis and of course
there's the worst possible case you can
have which is reciprocal sign up stasis
we're both both paths are blocked
alright and so if we look at sort of
what data we have on empirical fitness
landscapes we can see that you know
there's definitely some cases where
everything is smooth we have a smooth
fitness landscape there is no sign up of
stasis there's no super cosine epistasis
you start at the you know Louis fitness
genotype and then all the alleles are
adaptively flip in and you can get
really quickly to sort of the fittest
variant however there's also empirical
landscapes where you'll have both sign
up the stasis and reciprocal sign
epistasis right example here you'll have
to hi fitness genotypes and all the
everything written right as their
shortest adaptive path is to this
fitness local Fitness speak and for
these guys everything in blue their
shoulders up the paths to this mobile
fitness speak and for the green one it
depends on the particulars of how strong
the selection strengths are on those
edges all right
so in real fitness some people kind of
see all of these kind of things showing
up and so in particular we can't always
assume smooth fitness landscape so
definitely can't always assume that
there's one peak and we get to quickly
and general you might have several Peaks
that we have to worry about and we kind
of want to quantify quantify this in a
very sort of vague way and see where we
can get from it nothing to notice from
these Fitness landscapes is that it's on
for jeans right N equals 4 you know for
N equals 4 and squared into the NR the
same thing these are very very small
examples which is really hard to sing
anything on and sort of the best state
of the art experiments done this you'll
have N equals 6 n equals 8 you know we
really don't have a good idea of
detailed fitness landscapes for for
anything really i think that's not the
whole I beta-lactamase I think they were
saying that paper I think this is the
methyl vector I might be wrong yeah I
see you what she's room ok i might have
swapped my swipe my references I'll fix
that up but the idea is just to get you
a heuristic idea of what these what
these landscapes look like and so since
we're looking at these because we have
so little information about landscapes
we have to figure out how to proceed
with reasoning about them and in a lot
of Milan the standard ways to say ok
well I'll just pick my landscape
randomly which is kind of to me as a
computer science that's a very weird
thing to say because a lot of times
picking something randomly gives you a
lot of structure in that thing that
you've picked right and so as a computer
scientist I'm going to have to recreate
part of Paul's talk here and talk about
worst-case analysis but before it talk
about worst-case nice i'll talk about
sort of a biological model which gets an
easy way to look at epistasis rates kind
of standard with an old model of
epistasis probably not the most popular
anymore and probably everyone's familiar
with the NK model just for those that
aren't what you'll have is you'll have
some sort of simple gene interaction
network where I given G
interacts with K other genes right alone
drunk one for cables to it saying right
and what interacts means is it's fitness
depends on the value of the alleles in
the genes that interacts with so for
instance the fitness of X not here
depends also on what's put into x1 and
x2 and then the fitness of x2 maybe
depends on what's we're on x1 depend on
what's put into x2 and x3 right and your
overall fitness and calculators are some
over these interactions right so
and the genes that interact with
right so that's an NK model right and
will care in our case about NK models
for K equals zero which means no
interaction everything is independent
that's a smooth fitness landscape you
can just put the application one in each
place then we care about the case N
equals 1 which is a case that's
tractable and the case N equals 2 which
is the same as all other cases they're
all equally hard and we're going to show
that you know for k equals greater than
greater equal to its a que les complete
problem so we to introduce sort of means
justify a sentai professionals class or
but we're going to rely on this computer
scientists and this is one place where I
think computer scientists have something
to offer biology which you know it might
not be obvious a lot of physicists come
into this field they'll say well random
working work shall come out bring it
over from how used to do in cisco
mechanics computer science have to worry
a lot about how worst-case analysis
really relates to things like average
case nails and that mythical typical
case analysis right because when you
look me i'll say and software part that
you've engineered sometimes maybe the
worst atrocities irse never input the
worst cases right how do you put it and
so computers have thought a lot about
this and there's definitely all kinds of
disagreement on when it works when it
doesn't work obviously i think that
worst case analysis can tell us
something very useful about fitness
classes that we couldn't get otherwise
and what it can tell us is we'll look at
the space sort of of all fitness
landscapes all right and what we want
identify in there are the ones that are
actually president biology right to some
extent and let's say we're marriage this
idea of having quick paths to local
piece right let's say you know you just
I can't live in a world where that
doesn't exist right then through worse
case not so we can say okay well these
sort of fitness landscapes over here
have exponentially long walks so you
don't want them they're not part of your
typical set right all right we're
looking at some system where we know
things have an extremely quickly faster
linear logarithm
fast convergence right like in parts of
the immune response right and we'll say
okay well that's probably in this that
here we can prove that convergence
happens quickly and also come from work
worse case now so as to divide up our
space as a sort of first step right I'm
going on afterwards once we have some
idea figured out what the space looks
like we can start to say okay let's talk
about probability distributions over
this typical subset that we've
identified so work is not so let us cut
down what fitness not since we consider
to be reasonable fitness landscapes okay
so what happens for coffins and K model
well now we'll see a series of results
which will be the more handles you give
me the more weight i can left right so
if you tell me nothing about how
mutation works right it could be some
complicated learning algorithm at each
generation the mutation operator goes
and checks of some numbers are prime
solves a hard linear programming problem
and things like that if you tell me
nothing and but you let me assume that
psi equal to pls then in general you
won't have you will not have any local
Fitness peaked which you can get it in
polynomial time right there will be
landscapes that's the case now if you
let me be more like some of the
biological literature and say okay well
I'm an adaptation estai only care about
things that follow adaptive walks right
then we can don't even need the P night
was the pls condition right if we look
at point mutations on this genotype
space then for some conditions and for
some for some landscapes there will
every adapt that have to any local
Fitness peak will be of exponential
length right so it doesn't even matter
if you have some sort of natural
storyboards yeah and it doesn't even
matter if you sort of have a an
omnipotent bacteria rancher who sits
there and selects which adaptive
mutation gets to come in all right as
long as we just have to be adaptive no
matter how much guidance you try to give
them it'll still take you exponentially
long to find any local Fitness peak
right so it's a very strong result for
artists so you'll never be at that peak
and be able to say things like I'm at
that peak my mutation it will start to
drop but i'll talk more about the
approximate peaks that you cared about
as well towards towards the end but you
might say okay well these are pretty
complicated landscapes can you tell me
something stronger for a simpler
landscape so like I think k plus 2 is
ready pretty comput Leslie but even in
philly people have found this
distinction that as you go from Capo's
on through cables to everything is a
little bit more complicated right can
you tell me anything but okay well if
you give me more handles if you let me
specify more what we mean by how the
mutations happen then I can cut off even
more of the landscape space as
inaccessible right in particular we can
define this concept of semi smooth
fitness landscapes right so for smooth
fitness landscapes this is the only type
of up states that happens magnitude
stasis no no sign flipping right for
smooth fitness landscapes it's easy to
see that you can always converge in n
steps right because you always put in
and that from this matter before you go
into if you want your more careful
amounts of instead of steps in terms of
time or generations that will be selling
more careful analysis but we still
polynomial right if you allow me
reciprocal sign epistasis like the NK
model does then I show that it's hard so
instead let's say you'll allow me only
sign up stays on a single gene aqui
won't be ever on a pair of them right so
there's always a shortest adaptive path
right this this means we'll be in a
unique peak and it will always be from
anywhere you start there'll be an
adaptive path from there to that fittest
peak which is of Hamming distance
between you guys right so always be a
short path well you won't find it and
this comes from taking riddle from the
previous results were from looking at
palma mobile search these comes from
looking at the simplex algorithm let's
implement they define these tools
analyze them called autos a cyclic
unique sync orientations which basically
correspond to what i just called send
thickness landscapes and you can show
that okay well if we do that sort of
fitness fittest mutant always right
that's a strategy that happens when you
have a very very very very large
population right then again
exponentially long walk with you follow
through speed and you'll walk around
your hypercube until you finally get to
the peak right and you might say okay
well no one actually use that except for
maybe some genetic algorithms things you
know in reality we might use them like
strong selection week mutation right
where we pick one of the adaptive guys
at random right and even there you can
show it a little bit harder you can show
that with high probability refrigerator
yes you'll have the Fisher exponent with
high probability you'll have your e to
the lower bound by you today and the
third power to the one third nap chopper
heads in the g8 community so you showed
that the fitness landscape co kind of
yep some of things and I mean you know
you can try to look at the ones in
between right sometimes people say okay
well i select proportions their selected
strength and things like that you can
look at those variants some of these
serums are hard to prove so will be a
hard theorem to prove but there's no
real natural reason to expect that
things in between selection rules in
between on the simplex algorithm
community pivot rules in between will
get you something better there's no need
to expect that so in other words what
you happen to give me here give me more
control over how the mutations happen
and I cut off more of the fitness
landscape space on which you can find
your fitness Peaks your local Fitness
speaks efficiently okay so you might say
I don't care about actually when I say
I'm at a local Fitness because I
actually mean I'm at a local Fitness PQ
no that's a straw man I mean I'm near a
local Fitness peak in some vague sense
of near well there's three ways you can
be near well at least three ways there's
many ways you can define but that always
three ways that pop into my head that
you can be near okay so if by near you
mean you're you're a few adaptive steps
away from being a fitness speak then no
no you're not near it tour in that sense
of the word but these hardness results
well this is all assuming that pls not
equal to B if you mean that your fitness
is close to the fitness of a local peak
then let x star there be the fitnah
speak the local Fitness speak of lowest
fitness and you're not even
exponentially close to its fitness the
distribution DN came on okay model or
gets it doesn't matter
what did what decision I draw there's no
rubber looking at worst case I'm not
letting you trust what happens in the
worst cases I put some specification on
this network and I put specifications on
what these additive terms are and these
additive terms are polynomial in
whatever is my parameter complexity in
that ok right but yeah once you start
sampling things and there's the results
like you know if you sample the network
at random you sample the weights at
random then you get this graph of a lot
of local Peaks that are really easy to
get to right you can so sure that that
models the immune response relatively
well right but that's a that's really
extracting structure from randomness
right that randomness fix your log
structure here it's a worst case for
that specific build in such a way that
they're hard to hard to find the local
peeps okay so those are some sad results
I guess but there is one way you can't
have your local didn't speak and that's
to say that if my fitness is f of X
right and if for all mutants in my
neighborhood we have that my fitness is
greater than or equal to 1 minus yes
right so in other words there might be
some guys are further than me but
they're only fitter than me by the slip
this s amount right letter chosen for
suggestive purposes I'm very floor okay
yeah what about another definition of a
fitness peak which is that the fraction
of my beneficial mutations has gone to
the invention a small become small yeah
so this won't matter because these
neighborhood sizes are polynomial so
you're sampling is still going to be
upon the amount of time sampling there
right so for these exponential results
it doesn't matter that it's small still
be at least one right unless you're
actually at a fitness speak of at least
one nearby mutant and since you're
sampling you know there's any of them
when you're you when you find one in
time and you'll find it right so it
won't it's it's definitely matters in
practice right what we care about the
division do get them in your time you
get there in Angeles 17th or something
but in the case of suffering exponential
from from Paula knows I'm it does not
matter it certainly does leah has it
what's the the fraction of steps that
are beneficial to decrease say that
means go to a constant independent event
or yeah that's fine for time making i
can assume there's only just one of them
that's no easy story like is there a way
that you can make it so that it takes a
very long time to get to that stage with
as i have to think about that or no yeah
that's that's the question okay so most
of these models you start out with a
certain distribution of beneficials that
distribution will go down but you're
saying it's just never going to go down
to zero or close to zero and so I still
think that the fact that it goes way
down below some threshold matters so
sort of i mean the other thing that
always matters just when they go down is
also how big that selection strength gap
is yeah right because even if you have
one guy has a very very high selection
coefficient you have a one end chance of
sampling him because a high / coastal
take over the population right and this
is where the result that starts to
matter a little bit is we can achieve
this if if an entire polynomial in n + 1
over s but we cannot achieve it in time
and n and the natural logarithm of 1
over s so what is that second part
matter this second part really matters
when we want to look at cases what we
actually have data like I said the
beginning we don't have much data on
actual structure of the fitness of the
control structure well we have a lot of
data on the time dependence or the order
for the fitness time series right and
the classic example this is Lansky's
long term evolution experiment so we
have data like this we have the fitness
over some over over some long number of
generations right and so in terms of
this we can take our vision from the
flattest let it turn them around what
does it tell us well it tells us that on
these hard fitness landscapes s which is
the gaps between them between each each
each increase in Fitness can drop off as
a polynomial in n + 1 over T right but
it can't drop off as the exponential n
time right studies little gaps I think
you there's two qualifiers to announce
the directions here that well I could
pick a really nice fitness landscape
where to make a strong as fast as I
wanted of course there's no one will do
that yeah so what's the statement here
the quantifiers for hard fitness
landscape sleep of these hard examples
and if you allow me all of the NK model
for Gators to write on these hard cases
you cannot get exponential convergence
towards a local Fitness people to go
right and so the nice thing about lens
gives recent result is that this kind of
all things that they show all right they
show that you can't you don't get very
fast first towards NASA told in their
case but also extension courses instead
you get this sort of power law
conversion which translates into as
dropping off as as a over tea or a
soprano
they get from their fit so this gets you
in kind of a place where you have a lot
more data to play around with and say
okay well in here you know we're getting
this slowly increase in thickness cannot
tell us about something about the
structure that Fitness landscape
potential it right can at least help us
cut off some of the fitness landscape of
space I don't know I mean I'm how much
you want to really trust these
functional forms yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean if you actually look at this
carefully the miz line is actually
dropping off as s / t squared so it's
not even separated between you know
they're separating different kind of
polynomial of suffering on a very small
not very large data set this meant more
as a as a picture right but it does sort
of tell you how your to connect two
experiments right in a particular as I
just assumed in the first inning
discussion one of the ways you could
start and test these sort of models
right it started running little you know
Lansky like experiments right what do
you say okay well I find some and this
is these things I'm not clean now
biologist I probably isn't work at all
picking some you know this gene causes
and a protein machine cause discomfort I
relatively independent we know that from
some other observations then put some
tracer on them watch them if they have
if they're the combination satisfies you
know some satisfy believe problem that I
don't kill them if it doesn't that do
kill them and it's why can't make this
very hard landscape them to evolve in
and see how fast they evolve a nap in
that sort of landscape on the other hand
giving simple one and see if they get
that fast or scalings why would I want
to do that on the computer okay because
I computer you'll get these results for
sure the idea is if you want to look for
magic or something oh right i don't
believe in magic yeah yeah on the
computer yes oh so if you're half water
bottle challenge right if you let me
encode with it to send into into your
difficult problem then you won't get to
local Fitness peak right but the
fraction could still drop to be so rare
that I don't ever generate them and so I
still have the same result it'll drop
off like this I'll drop off like the yes
line right you really really want that
water bottle um but you know we can talk
about yet I don't go to the word ok and
then where's the case where we can
really worried about this um you know
before we kind of worst-case analysis
the easiest way for computer science
justifying worst-case analysis is to say
you know adversarial right an adversary
builds my fitness landscape and that's
exactly what we saw earlier today right
um you know he's like the immune system
where the host is picking the fitness
don't give her the pattern ship to adapt
on and making the worst one possible
well he's speaking it but but he's big
name but he said up into it yeah yeah
there's there's research on how it's
picking but that's that comes up just so
still the computer science problem can
you can rate heart is a problems that
the name can't solve right right but
here so you have a good to other series
with the hands tied together it's not
the same extent yeah but in this case is
I think you can make a much better
justification for wine or good the
landscape would be the worst is possible
and then this might get you some maybe
intuition about cases like once again I
don't know anything about biology but in
cases like you know let's say HIV where
your genotype is constantly changing
right can you look at those things as
artifact to the fact that opinions is
nutrition builds a fitness landscape
before that for the bars which we should
never find a local optimum so it keeps
chasing something constantly no
existence gets to them okay but really
other ones um right and performing for
examples like that obscene if see if
that's a useful thing to think about and
yeah and so I guess the whole point of
the talk is to sort of figure out how to
take our assumptions we make them very
precise
do they always add up not really in this
case you know if you like again tomorrow
for some reason but you also like the
idea of finding the local Fitness speaks
quickly you have to cut off parts of the
possible fitness landscapes in order for
this to work right or if you like your
strong selection big mutation model of
an adaptation right then you really do
cut off huge parts of your fitness
landscape for them to find fittings
quickly so yeah which means it could
have huge parts yes so like that result
I'm free to take our semi smooth fitness
landscapes and you still get Harvin
walks right so that right tells you that
there's this it'sit's um that's just 0
worst case everything is worst case and
it's what is its are some of these where
the worst cases has some sizable
fraction it's only like decreasing
polynomial II with the size or what do
you mean sizable fraction of what like a
weird like a polynomial a small fraction
of total number of landscapes so this is
Lisa 40 gets average case analysis right
so when you start up about the fractions
right what you said is I assume the
uniform distribution over fitness
landscapes and if I sample from your
distribution or fitness landscapes do I
have a nonzero probability chance of
sampling essential question how that
series you don't know we can we would
have a huge stage to say look at Google
for Ricky deficit Frances a monic
polynomial many heart distances because
you take one heart instance kind of
padded for something bigger artisans and
they have a lot of parts of slightly
bigger size perfect for these photos
show zero Musial the the semi spinoza
but it has it you're saying that if you
restrict it to the closet landscapes
which a semi-smooth which is a small
fraction to space there is still ones
that you can't dirty yes yes yes and you
can blow those up also to be not like a
tiny fraction by patting sort of
arguments but you can't sail it to any
fresh so not a tiny precious i'm like
more not a sparse 60 more than potter
than many of them right we're mostly
many of them but that doesn't get your
x-men to the boot the space X minus the
big you more fun when many of them
doesn't actually mean that you have a
nonzero property of sampling none right
once again because Exponential's are
mean to me but the whole point of this
that I sonic in the beginning is that
these arguments when you ask this what
fraction of them you're implicitly
asking you to put a probability
distribution on the space right and you
asked me to put the uniform one and the
idea is that if this is Agnes landscape
if it's coming from some ecology or
something that the organism lives in
there's no reason to assume that those
are colleges are somehow sample randomly
I'm asking if you knew if i want to find
his worst cases i need to assume some
really extreme probability distribution
it's hard to say you're asking for the
mythical typical case and then the whole
point of this was is to is to kind of
help identify what that typical cases by
by cutting off parts of the edits
landscape space
all right thank you